the recent Russian attacks on Ukraine
hit 12 cities as well as the human cost
it's estimated it devastated a third of
the country's infrastructure that'll
take money to rebuild which is why
President Vladimir zielinski asked the
International Financial Community to
step up
the more assistance the Ukraine gets now
the sooner we will come to the end of
the Russian war
he estimates Ukraine will need
significant injections of funds just to
run the country in 2023 and billions
more to rebuild it
38 billion dollars to make up for the
deficit of our budget for next year
including salaries for doctors and
teachers another 17 billion to rebuild
critical infrastructure schools
hospitals critical transport and energy
infrastructure and also housing
the United States has already pledged 15
billion dollars in support for Ukraine
and the international monetary fund
hosting this meeting on Ukraine with the
World Bank says it understands the
urgency of action our team is going to
be with Ukrainian a team uh immediately
after the annual meetings to determine
the macroeconomic framework and also
what that would mean in terms of
budgetary implications our preliminary
estimate is that somewhere between two
sorry three and four billion dollars are
necessary on a monthly basis the
Ukrainian economy has been devastated by
the war with Russia GDP gross domestic
product which is the normal way to judge
the financial strength of a country is
down by more than 30 percent inflation
the cost of goods is soaring and there
is unemployment because 47 percent of
companies have closed their door the
International Financial Community is
aware of the impact the war is having
globally and it sees the need to help
Ukraine to bring stability back for its
sake and theirs Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
at the IMF meeting in Washington